non elle continue et se débat pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe froguel
chercheur généticien bonsoir fifres gad
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct je le rappelle à chaque fois mais
enfin vous avez quand même été le
premier je m'en souviens il ya très
longtemps à nous dire que omicron si
omicron ne s'avérait pas dangereux ce
serait peut-être vous l'aviez à l'époque
la fin de la pandémie en tout cas on
irait vraiment dans le bon sens
aujourd'hui on le voit il ya les
optimistes y est les plus pessimistes
vous vous vous situez dans quel camp
moi je pense que ça dépend des deux
camps on parle on est en france en tout
cas on est à cinq cent mille cas par
jour on n'est pas au pic et c'est pas
une surprise parce que on a quinze jours
de retard à paris à peu près trois
semaines un mois dans le reste de la
france et donc le pic si vous
conseillons total de cas ça sera
probablement à la fin du mois mais
ensuite je pense que ça va baisser et
s'est rapidement comment en afrique du
sud comme en angleterre et je pense que
j'espère que si le variant delta
disparaît comme il en train de faire
bousman mais sûrement eh bien on va s'en
sortir par les hôpitaux ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il n'est pas des gens qui vont
encore mourir mais ça sera pas au niveau
de la santé publique le drame qu'on a
connu ces derniers temps alors on espère
évidemment que la fin de cette épidémie
pandémie peu importe comment on
l'appelle mais en tout cas que le virus
nous laisse tranquille n'est ce pas
parmi les pessimistes beaucoup évoquent
de nouveaux variants éventuel également
ses 4 milliards d'êtres humains qui sont
toujours non vaccinés pour vous ces deux
éléments représentent qu il a un danger
oui c'est bien entendu un danger de
théorique simplement micro est vraiment
très très très contagieux ça va être
difficile pour un autre variant de faire
mieux que lui mais ce que dit aussi le
directeur de l' oms et que je je pense
que c'est tout à fait vrai c'est que il
faut avancer vers un vaccin de deuxième
génération qui puisse couvrir pas
simplement au micro ou la suite de
micron mais beaucoup plus large et qui
puisse aussi couvrir l'ensemble des
possibles modifications de ces ars co2
puisque c'est le nom du du virus et ça
c'est très possible
simplement ce n'est pas sûr que les
vaccins arn soit ce dont on a besoin en
2002 2022 ou 2023 alors il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui s'interrogent notamment
en france envoie que le royaume uni lève
ses restes section l'espagne dit vouloir
traiter ce virus comme une grippe alors
qu'en france finalement elle renforce
les protocoles avec un pass vaccinale on
connaît le casse-tête dans l'est dans
les écoles quelle position adopter
aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup doutent
d'eux que ces restrictions soient encore
nécessaires
avec cinq cent mille cas répertoriés par
jour c'est à dire probablement à 800
milles 1 million en réalité en fait tout
le monde est touché et on le voit bien
autour de autour de nous
moi je prône les autotests pour au moins
protéger ses proches et puis éviter de
contaminer d'autres personnes
ensuite effectivement une grande partie
de la population française va être
atteinte par au micron qui soient
vaccinées ou non vacciner puisque le
vaccin est relativement peu efficace
contre les formes bénignes de micron
efficace contre les formes graves
apparemment
mais aujourd'hui il faut attendre que le
pic descendent faire le plus attention
pour soi même et ses proches et je pense
que en février ça ira mieux et là on
pourra faire comme l'angleterre comme en
espagne avoir
considéré comme niveau sociétal la ville
doit recommencer comme avant vous
parliez du vaccin on parle de plus en
plus
des médicaments pfizer vient d'en sortir
un est ce que c'est une vraie
alternative aujourd'hui pour vous
difficultés du médicament de pfizer
c'est qui doit être remis ce très très
très rapidement et pas l'hôpital puisque
c'est avant que ça se joue et c'est pas
absolument évident aujourd'hui les
médecins généralistes que j'ai consulté
les aides les unions professionnelles
n'ont rien reçu de gouvernement sur une
approche claire à qui et comment
distribuer ce médicament j'ai bien peur
que ce médicament reste dans les
pharmacies ne soient pas utilisés
merci philippe froguel chercheur
généticien merci nous avoir apporté
votre analyse ce soit